[Music]
in response to russia's invasion of
ukraine the u.s and allies have
attempted a stranglehold on russian
banks companies and oligarchs but some
wonder what makes an oligarch and how
did they become so rich the classic
definition of an oligarch would include
social and political influence but since
the war began most of russia's
billionaires have little or no sway with
russian president vladimir putin
russia's original oligarchs made their
fortunes in the 1990s during the chaotic
aftermath of the soviet union's collapse
state assets were offloaded to private
bidders often in corrupt deals this was
a period of market liberalization where
businessmen former officials and
entrepreneurs acquired large stakes in
russian oil and gas mining
transportation agricultural products and
other core industries between 1992 and
1994 the newly independent russian
federation ran a voucher privatization
effort under the program shares of some
15 000 state-owned firms were made
available to private buyers its aim was
to allow ordinary russians to buy shares
instead well-connected businessmen
acquired blocks of vouchers giving them
large or controlling stakes in firms
under the program two-thirds of all
privatized shares came to be held by
company insiders according to a 1999
international monetary fund study
russia's 1998 financial crisis was a
temporary setback for the oligarchs
soaring commodity prices and russia's
increasing economic integration into the
west in the 2000s minted dozens of new
tycoons some newer oligarchs became
wealthy through their ties to putin who
has ruled russia in one form or another
since 2000 in 2001 russia had eight
billionaires worth a collective 12.4
billion dollars in 2021 10 years later
there were 101 billionaires worth
432.7 billion dollars according to
forbes data
putin has both enriched and punished
oligarchs treating them as pawns in his
political chess matches mikhail
kordakovsky then russia's richest man
was arrested in 2003 for tax crimes
after he supported putin's political
rival kordakovsky said the charges were
fabricated and he was pardoned and
released in 2013. the oligarchs learned
their wealth was conditional on
obedience to putin but many of today's
oligarchs are current or former putin
officials as putin has consolidated
power and asserted state control over
more private businesses a new breed of
oligarch emerged the seal of ark
the word combines oligarch and siloviki
russian for the country's military and
security elite many see levars know
putin personally from his time in the
kgb or from working under him in saint
petersburg during his early post-soviet
political career oligarchs face a rocky
future as the west punishes putin's
russia as of march 14th 20 of them are
under personal sanction by the u.s and
its allies it no longer seems to matter
which side russia or ukraine they've
taken oligarchs who've sold their
russian assets and moved their holdings
to the west are hurriedly distancing
themselves from putin and his regime
many of them are being slapped with
sanctions anyway sea levarx and those
with russian assets haven't been
protected by putin and they've seen
their fortunes plummet as russian
markets collapse